Forget IP ownership and movie rights and all that legal nonsense
There's one reason and one [reason] only the x-men universe has to stay separate from the rest of Marvel's properties because you know
Magneto would have his way with anyone named iron man
Quickest battle ever
Hello, internet
Welcome to film theory the show that's calling out the film industry [for] a serious lack [of] imagination in their posters this year Batman V
Superman Civil [war]
Neighbors [to]
Noticing a pattern here guys and sure the trend nowadays is to just slap two superheroes together and have them duke it out the x-Men
Have been doing that for well over a decade
These mutants never got along come on wolverine you don't have to punch deadpool in the face
Hey [a] jean grey would be great if you didn't disintegrate
Cyclops all right Charles [Eric] can the two of you act like adults and not try to kill each other for just one movie?
No, no not even once and it ain't stopping anytime soon either since there's another mutant war on the Horizon in x-Men apocalypse
[so] knowing that it's high time [we] start looking into the powers of these extra normal humans and prep some
Strategies for how to handle some of the Franchise's heaviest hitters and who better to start with than Magneto
[I] mean when I was a wee
Eight-year-old educating my classmates on the proper hand hand traction for swinging on the monkey bars
There was only one thing I wanted to be a mutant sign me up for xavier school for gifted Youngsters
Aka
American
Hogwarts teach me how to throw a car with my mind or shoot laser beams out of my eyes or freeze a pencil in thin
Air you know practical everyday
Useful stuff or at least as useful as I found calculus to be in my everyday life
But amongst all the awesome mutants and awesome powers there is one who stood out from the rest the most awesome one of all
Magneto and yeah, yeah flame or in the comments
All you Wolverine fans, please snikt away your retractable claws and get honest with yourselves for a moment Wolverine is great
Don't get me wrong
But can he stop a bullet in Midair can he lift a car without even touching it head he?
fly I don't [think] so, you know who can Magneto and
probably storm [two]
She could probably do those things jean along with a few others in the x-men universe since those sorts of powers aren't really that rare
To come by that just makes Wolverines inability to do them all the more unacceptable
But will be rants aside when you really look at it
the story of the x-Men movies for the last 15 years has truly been the story of [Magneto] his
relationship with professor x and yet in writing this episode
I was disillusioned because for his grandiose as he talks and his powerful as he seems when you get right [down] to it
Magneto is one of the most vulnerable mutants in all of these films the guy's a glass cannon powerful
But fragile and his biggest weakness [one] that you could use to take him down yourself is one that you probably
Wouldn't expect now to truly appreciate Magneto's one fatal flaw we have to first understand just how he does what he does
What makes the guy tick the source behind all his powers?
Magnets who would have ever guessed but for as simple as that explanation is there's actually a lot [more] to it than that no
I'm gonna guess that the elementary teacher who had you play with horseshoe magnets and [paperclips] in school didn't tell you that there are actually?
six different types of Magnetic Force
Six they you'll be looking at those refrigerator magnets in a whole new way now the six different types are diamagnetism
paramagnetism
ferromagnetism
[antiferromagnetism] [Faerie] Magnetism and Super Para magnetism of those the type we're almost familiar with is Ferro
Magnetism this type occurs when an object's electrons all point the same way attracting materials to it
It's the strongest and most easy to identify type of magnetism and yet it only works on items
Consisting of iron Nickel Cobalt their alloys and a few other naturally occurring minerals. It's actually really easy to remember
ferromagnetic from the Word Ferrous meaning containing iron think back to the periodic table
We were all confused why fe stood for iron right well?
Ferro
Gotta love those ancient root words and seriously think back to those classroom experiments you did when you were in first grade a magnet could
Pick up a paperclip largely comprised of iron, but could pick up your pencil made of wood so simple stuff
I know
But I [gotta] make sure that you guys stick with this episode
Stick with it
Like a magnet all right now while I could take you through the other five types of magnetism after looking through all the x-Men films
Magneto seems not to be the master of [Magnetism] so much as he is the master of Ferro Magnetism since every single
Thing that Magneto lifts seems like it would have traces of iron Nickel Cobalt or an alloy the Golden Gate bridge
Which Magneto lifts in x-men the last [stand] the main Towers and suspended structures are made of steel the ballistic missiles Magneto stops in x-Men?
First class shells made of steel the rFK baseball stadium he lifts in days of future past
Constructed from a base of [steel] even Wolverine throughout the x-Men films we see Magneto
constantly bending and manipulating Wolverines claws
Seriously, it's almost like a running joke the number of times they've used this trick and yet
We as the movie-going audience are always like oh
He's totally schooling Wolverine as though. We didn't just see it in like the last 30 movies
We get it his skeleton is metal all right find a new way to beat the guy anyway per Marvel or [Wolvie] Skeleton claws
Included are made of adamantium which despite being a fictional metal is a very dense
Artificial iron based alloy according to Canon even fake metals have iron in them
so in short
You can think of Magneto as a permanent magnet
attracting and controlling specific types of materials this would explain why an x [-] x-Men united when Magneto's held in the
Plastic cell he's rendered completely
Powerless in order to Escape the cell mystique [has] to inject a prison guard with none other than iron when the prison guard has extra
Iron running through him Magneto is able to lift a man and extract the iron from his body much
the same way A
Permanent Magnet does in retrospect, that's a silly sentence that would imply that
permanent Magnets on the regular Lifts humans often extract iron from them gives Magnets a weird
Evil intent that I didn't anticipate, but just how strong of a magnet is he well the biggest feat
We see him perform across all the movies is that aforementioned Golden gate bridge scene from last [Stan] a structure weighing
887 Thousand Tons, or
804 million kilograms based on the bridges weight and the magnetic strength required to generate enough lift to levitate other much smaller
objects we were able to calculate that the strength of Magneto's Magnetic field would be in the range of
100 million Tesla a Magnetic Force that can only be found in Neutron Stars by comparison
You know what the strongest magnet we have on Earth is a hundred Tesla
[100] oh yeah, and by the way hashtag not spawn by Tesla the car companies just that Nikola Tesla
Did all Sorts of cool stuff [in] short Magneto is 1?
Million times stronger than any magnet we've been able to produce here on Earth. That's insane
How do you stop a juggernaut like that on the geminal pitch?
That's a whole lot [easier] than you think bullets seriously you just shoot him remember Magneto is ferromagnetic
So not all metal is under his control and bullets by and large are made with a lead core in case with a copper jacket
[both] of which are
non-Magnetic
materials which means Magneto should have no more control over a bullet than he would the
Plastic cell from x 2 or even a plastic water bottle for that matter if you watch the series with this knowledge
You'll notice that throughout the x-men films Magneto shows very little success at stopping bullets in the famously awesome
Quicksilver time in a bottle sequence Magneto has complete control over all [the] kitchen utensils
but it's up to
Quicksilver to deflect the bullets and save Erik and Charles's life and then at the end of days of future passed
Mystique shoots Magneto in the neck the movie makes it seem like this [is] because Magneto's distracted by the sentinel but in truth
It's because his magnetic powers don't extend to bullets now. I can totally see you being skeptical about this
What about that awesome scene from the first x-men movie where Magneto is surrounded by the police officers?
I hear you saying he stops a bullet right [there], and yeah, you're right. He does stop a bullet in that scene
let's pick it apart shall we Magneto starts the scene by turning each of the officers guns against them and this falls well under the
Purview of his powers as most guns are made from aluminum and steel so no big surprise and a really cool really intense image
But then Magneto fires one of the guns and stops the bullet
Itself at the base [of] the officers forehead if what I'm saying is true, [and] he can't control bullets. How's this work?
Well my first impulse was to say that this bullet must be what's known as a full metal jacket Bullet and no
I'm not talking about a transmuting anime bullet or an 80s cinema classic bullet
But a lead bullet jacketed and steel to allow for higher
Velocity shooting if this were the case it would [be] easy for Magneto to control except that we get a good look [at] that bullet
Spinning in Midair and it doesn't have the long more
Aerodynamic shape of a full metal bullets further complicating [the] situation is [that] in the late 90s several major cities in the us including?
New York setting for the scene stopped using full metal jacketed bullets in favor of Hollow point
[Hst] [Mu] [Ition] Bullets designed to
Expand once they hit the intent is to cause a high level of damage immediately around the entry point which disables the targets these
HsT bullets tend to be shorter and rounder and are jacketed not with steel
But with copper a non-Ferrous almost completely non
Ferromagnetic metal meaning that in the real world the bullets carried by the majority of major us cities would be totally unaffected by Magneto's powers
In other words, they would definitely pose a threat to him, but they wouldn't explain this situation at all
So what's going on here am I completely off the mark in my analysis of Magneto's powers?
[oh], no, watch the seat again first notice the shape of the bullet shorter and more rounded so it's definitely our hST [bullet]
But notice the color of the bullet silver and not yellow orange like copper also
It's important to note that this standoff is happening at night these two facts are essential because law enforcement agencies have reported
That in [Low-light] low velocity shooting situations
They'll use special nickel casings for their hollow-point ammo nickel a metal that's completely susceptible to
ferromagnetism, and that is exactly what we're seeing need more evidence tangents of the fact that Magneto doesn't fire at every officer surrounding him he
only fires this one
particular Bullet why he carefully searches his
surroundings almost as if he's looking for the right gun to fire the one out [of] the dozens that
Doesn't have lead in Copper Bullets for instance
He doesn't fire a shotgun shell because shotgun shells often contain a mix of ferrous and non-ferrous metals. No he specifically selects the bullet
He can control and if you think I'm reading too much into it don't trust me trust him Magneto himself admits to it
I don't think I can stop them all he's not talking about the number [of] bullets. He would be firing remember
This is the guy who can lift the golden gate bridge and catch dozens of Missiles in Midair
[he] honestly can't stop them all his powers won't
allow it so in the end the master of Magnetism [a] mutant with power levels rivaling that of a neutron star my
Favorite growing up in a man who can rip apart?
bridges with a flick of the wrist can be brought down by [A]
Simple Bullet
Just like you or me what he's been able to do is fool everyone into thinking [that] he can control bullets when the vast majority
Of them pose huge threat to him forget adamantium blades and laser eyes
sometimes the most
Effective weapon is the simplest I guess giving Wolverine a hard time about not being able to stop bullets in Midair was a bit premature
[but] hey, that's just a theory a film theory and
Cut and hey if you enjoyed this episode and are excited [for] more x-men apocalypse
action click right here to check [out] my buddies over at the Wisecrack channel and their recent video all about the
philosophy of the X-Men series the annotation works on mobile desktop
tablet you name it so [go] ahead click it watch their video you have no excuse now or if you're interested [in] learning how to
Take down Wolverine
I cover that exact subject in my deadpool episode because the two actually share the exact same
Weakness click right here to check that one out and now if you'll excuse [me]. I need a little break from superheroes
I hear there's some pixar movies coming out in the near future and some lies that need to be exposed. See you next time